[Music]
what up anime fans welcome to episode 78
review of Dragon Ball super and there's
so much to talk about this time and the
a let's just jump right into it so we
start this episode learning more about
the tournament and of course it's
revealed that the universe's that don't
win are gonna be erased and of course
Goku can be seen as the biggest mass
murderer in history for causing this but
to be fair to everyone who's saying that
and to the other side I mean the fact is
that he didn't know that so much would
be on the line he couldn't foresee this
that being said though he is way too
carefree this episode just considering
how many people's lives are in danger
and even if they win all these other
universes are gonna be destroyed it's
gonna go fine with that or has he
figured out a plan to somehow get out of
it or just confident that they will get
out of it somehow cuz if so that would
be kind of unforeseen and maybe even
aren't characteristic planning ahead on
Goku's part but we'll see who knows it
would be nice to see Goku go up some IQ
points this arc when we're learning
about the tournament of power of course
the Zen match exhibition that's going to
take place before that we learn it's
gonna be take place in this world of
void which is a very interesting idea
and apparently there's no time or space
within this world so I'm wondering how
that's gonna affect the fighters
wondering if it's going to be able to
use this time-skip ability I'm not sure
what that's gonna entail but they said
it so I'm guessing it's gonna play some
kind of factor how are you gonna work
function in a space with no place or
time kind of weird to think about and
again we have Vegeta refusing absolutely
refusing to go while go who invited him
but at the same time Goku did I
mentioned that the universes are gonna
be on the line for the tournament which
is probably a smart move considering
Vegeta and he'll probably kill him
I mean literally Vegeta has taken like I
said last episode of 180 and I feel like
Goku has been just regressing more and
more Super Saiyan I guess while the jito
is becoming more and more human so we'll
see what happens but right now it seems
like Goku is turning out to be like a
villain more villainous than Bews than
the god of destruction and Vegeta is
turning out to be like a hero so we'll
see what happens we'll see how that
dynamic might switch up and how it's
gonna be complicated but right now it's
pretty interesting stuff happen then we
get a moment where he tells Gohan and go
Han is upset with him but like not died
of cells then I guess as upset as Gohan
gets which is not that much but yeah he
is upset with him and in the end he gets
over pretty quick surprisingly but
there's this one beautiful moment where
you can see him and I'll show it on
screen here and then you can see Vidal
and pan in the background and he says
there's something that I want to protect
and so he will come and that was an
awesome moment I love how they caught
him in the frame while he said that I
think that was really good
cinematography on Dragon Ball super his
part and to be honest guys I've been
really liking these slice-of-life
moments they seem to be much more
prevalent in Dragon Ball super than they
weren't Dragon Ball Z as I recall giant
Ball Z was more about the fighting the
prolonged fighting albeit but the
fighting with very few moments in
between for emotion they were usually
tied into the fighting but here we were
seeing a lot of slice of life and if you
guys know anything about me you know
that I do love slice of Life a lot and I
think Dragon Ball super is not getting
worse by doing this I think it's a good
thing and I hope they keep it up it's
great to see Gohan back in the orange
and blue uniform again so awesome to see
and it means he's gonna be getting back
into it back to some of that old Gohan
glory hashtag make Gohan great again
anyway so yeah we're gonna be seeing
that he's gonna hopefully take off his
glasses when he fights you know
apparently going super saiyan might help
your vision I don't know but it'll
probably take off his glasses and we'll
see awesome fight so I look forward to
that and I look forward to a strong
opponent it's gonna push Gohan to the
limit and bring back that Gohan who
loves to fight and I hope we'll see more
of that Gohan to come and I feel like
this is a good step cuz finally we're
gonna see some real Gohan fighting
action just like we're finally gonna see
for the first time in DBZ since DBZ Buu
fighting action which is gonna be sick
and we've been getting a really focus on
Goku's impoliteness and just the fact
that even people were calling him
impudent scum because of the way he was
acting so it's gonna be interesting to
see how all the other gods and fighters
react to Goku's let's say lack of proper
etiquette and just being you know polite
person in general especially you know in
Japan Japanese society that's a big deal
so Goku definitely stands out and it's
gonna be interesting to see if even the
xenos eventually get and get enough of
his just impudence I guess so we'll see
or maybe they'll just be keep on being
his friend and we'll see cuz if we
remember that there was that moment in
the last episode where does enols put up
their hands and then ones I know saw
that the others are had their other hand
up and then they put up that one so that
was interesting I don't think it's just
you know for fun to be cute because it
happened a few times and I feel like
it's gonna be important clearly they're
not the same person there's different
experiences different realities have
made them into different people and I
feel like that's gonna be important
later where I'm guessing there's gonna
be some kind of conflict the two xennos
not gonna be disagree on something maybe
the fate of the universes and that will
have to play itself out sometime so I
wouldn't be surprised if one of these
idols turns out to be the bad guy in
this season and we're finally gonna see
Buu fight and that's what I'm gonna be
one of the wolf creatures
that we've been introduced to and I'm
really excited and I mean the fact that
at first he was getting his butt kicked
which was hilarious
and then we see does a nose even say wow
that guy's going pretty fast which was
hilarious because fir dam is probably
like really like maybe four alive it's
fast and wow it's probably fast but
anyways the fact that boo smiled in the
end that was the close up of a smile
that was the perfect way to get to end
the episode it was just awesome and I
mean it gets us to almost to hype for
the next absolute sync you know you
can't do this to us and I like this I
love to see what he has to offer because
like I said it was not since Dragonball
Z that we saw him really fight so this
is gonna be amazing I can't wait to see
what happens and I'm excited about a lot
of other stuff as well I'm excited to
see Android 18 fight because she hasn't
been really a part of a lot of things
that she's gonna be part of this lineup
I'm gonna enjoy seeing Android 17 come
back I'm good up I'm just enjoyed the
fact that we have a god of destruction
that appears to be a woman and we're
starting to get a lot of strong female
characters including what seemed to be
kaaba's sister something i've called
called her a or just female Brawley like
we're it's gonna be interesting to see
how all these female characters play out
and how well they do in the tournament
that's gonna be very interesting to see
also excited to see that part in the
intro that people have been talking
about whether that actually comes to
fruition whether that is a new form you
know the part where he's actually looks
kind of like he's giving an evil smirk
he has black hair but with a red aura
around it I'm looking forward to see if
that's a new form and some people are
not optimistic but I think I think I'm
looking for that I think that wouldn't
be out of the realm of possibility and I
think it's gonna happen some kind of new
form at the very least mastering Kaioken
that's gonna be interesting to see ya
guys overall I think the coolest part of
this episode was the reveal of all of
the gods of destruction and their
helpers I mean yes we kind of got sneak
previews in the magazines and stuff but
this is the first time we act
you get to see them in the actual show
it's awesome and of course the god of
destruction that was right over there
that looks like a cloud like the Joker
that guy obviously I'm commented before
that's gonna be a very important
universe especially that person's hiding
his identity
shrouded over there in a hood and like
robes
I feel like that'll be a very important
character it's the only character that's
hiding themselves so that universe just
in general looks like it's gonna be a
big part and it's gonna be it's gonna be
interesting to see I I I really want to
know who that person is gonna be if you
have any idea or any speculations
theories let me know in the comments
below cuz I mean I there's no doubt in
my mind that when they reveal their
identity that's gonna switch the game up
it's gonna be it's gonna be a powerful
opponent or something like that in some
way it's gonna be
groundbreaking so I can't wait to see
who that is
I'm excited I'm really excited if
someone should be excited about it all
these different different gods of
destruction looking at all of them just
wondering how powerful they are looking
at their designs gonna be looking at all
of the other fighters it's gonna be so
interesting just all this world building
I'm really loving it universe is
building it's gonna be amazing to see
another thing is what's gonna happen
with all these universes I doubt they're
actually get destroyed but can we keep
letting Goku get away with all of his
stupid actions while of his careless
actions cuz Vegeta has been working on
himself and we've seen that in previous
arts but Goku is still careless as ever
it seemed he wasn't that bullet showed
it
when he got scratched by the bullet and
now we see like him engaging all these
lives and he was warned not to he pushes
the button so are we gonna have some
meaningful repercussions here or not I
mean is it gonna be that super Dragon
Ball is putting them into the mix is
universe 7 gonna win and then wish all
the universes back or would it be more
interesting to see if another universe
wins and then they save universe 7 and
go quest and think about what he's done
are there gonna be some kind of actual
consequences are gonna stick with goku
like it seems there should be because
again and again he's messing up like I
mean it seems like it's really catching
up and that shot that scratch they got
for that bullet really seem to be
foreboding something so what do you guys
think is gonna happen what kind of way
could they play this arc where Goku
learned something something is lost but
in the end not all of the universe's are
destroyed or hopefully any so we'll see
what happens I I don't know what to
think at this point we'll see so anyways
guys that's what I thought about this
episode and what's gonna happen possibly
in the future if you guys like these
kinds of videos give it a thumbs up and
also subscribe if you haven't already
until next time see you space cowboys